the following conversation is with adam
kirkowitz he's the managing director of
investments at washington university in
st louis adam and i have a fantastic
discussion we do a deep dive on
endowment investing including portfolio
construction asset allocation how he
thinks about evaluating alternative
assets and what exactly is the purpose
of an endowment including their
strengths and weaknesses i really
enjoyed this conversation with adam and
i hope you guys enjoy it as well let me
know in the comments what you learned
from it and i'll be in there later to go
ahead and answer some of your questions
here is my conversation with adam
kirkowitz i hope that you enjoy it all
right guys i've got adam here with me uh
i'm very excited about this conversation
i think that uh we talked to tons of
investors we talked to tons of founders
but we don't really talk to that many
kind of institutional asset allocators
so uh maybe let's start with just like
what is an endowment people have heard
that term they know that it's important
but uh it's a very unique type of asset
allocator so how would you describe what
an endowment is yeah absolutely um so an
endowment is basically a
at a university a separate pool of
capital from operating funds that's
generally funded by gifts over many
years so in washu's case in st louis uh
the university is founded in 1853
uh the endowment today is about 14 15
billion dollars now uh a lot of that
it's like there's 14 billion dollars of
gifts a lot of that is small gifts over
many many many decades that compound
over many many uh
you know at a moderate rate over
extremely long periods of time
um the purpose of the endowment is at a
high level to be a permanent source of
income
uncorrelated to
you know tuition grants hospital revenue
for universities that have affiliated
hospital systems uh to support whatever
mission you know the university has so
the vast majority of those funds are
actually earmarked for specific purposes
so if you want to give to your alma
mater and say i want to have kev the
awesome you know business podcast
professorship at the business school
uh they might come to you and say okay
that's going to cost a million of capex
or you know annual operating expenses
to fund that
the endowment pays out about five
percent of its asset a year to support
those initiatives so you've got to give
20x that effectively to create the
income from that asset to support that
initiative so that's that's effectively
what it is it's not used it's again it's
separate from operating funds
it's not used to pay electricity bills
salaries things like that it's generally
for very long term stuff to support
specific research research initiatives
tuition relief
um some of it is unrestricted you could
give a gift to your alma mater and say
use it however you want i don't care but
the vast majority certainly of wash use
but i think most institutions is
restricted for specific purposes
given that this is permanent capital
very long-term oriented
endowments are different types of
investors what would you say the main
differences are between the way an
endowment approaches investing versus
maybe other types of market participants
yeah i mean if you think about
our objective
with this pool of capitals we pay out
about four to five percent and this is
similar for most endowments pay out
about four to five percent of the assets
every year
we have an inflation rate a
long-term inflation rate i'll ignore the
current inflation environment for a
second uh that's actually higher than
what historical cpi or pce has been for
broad consumers so call it four to five
percent three to five percent something
like that
um and if you want to have real growth
on top of that you're talking about you
know double digit
uh you know types uh types of outcomes
so
we have to take an amount of risk that
allows us to meet those annual cash
distributions the university
but also enables us to generate
significant long-term performance so
that we don't spend down the real
purchasing power of that pool of assets
over time
um
so basically uh the portfolio is um
it has an amount of fixed income and
cash that can support a couple of years
of
uh distributions back to university we
have some medium-term assets that take a
little bit
less risk so that if you were an extreme
drawdown scenario you would what you
don't want to do is sell risk assets at
depressed prices so you have some kind
of medium risk assets whether it could
be real estate cash generating assets
lower net exposure hedge funds those
types of things would be the typical
things that an endowment would have in
that kind of bucket
and then the rest is going to be
risk effectively
i would say wash use a little bit
different we can we can get into that
even from other endowments but generally
speaking
uh you know endowments are are kind of
allocating a lot of their capital to
alternative asset classes you know
venture capital increasingly crypto
uh private equity real estate things
like that where you can have more
idiosyncratic or outlier types of assets
a significant part of our capital is
also invested in public markets but
zooming out to like relative to pensions
insurance companies family offices to
get to your question i would say we're
more risk oriented those organizations
often look very similar to one another
and it's a matter of how much risk
broadly defined they take so with a
pension or an insurance company your
liabilities are contractual
washu has some control
over what the distribution rate from the
endowment is every year so but if you're
a pensioner like you are you are legally
entitled to a certain dollar payment on
a certain date for a fixed schedule so
those institutions just structurally
have to take less risk than than say an
endowment where we can we can actually
cut our spending rate a little bit if we
have to in a down environment i don't
think a lot of people quite understand
how big these endowments are obviously
wash you 14 15 billion uh i'll say this
so that you don't have to you guys are
one of the best endowments in the world
and in terms of asset allocation and
investment a lot of the capital uh is
derived from the gifts and kind of from
a university focus but obviously you
guys have done a great job investing
over uh last few decades uh there's
other endowments that are even bigger
right some are 20 30 40 billion dollars
uh in size as well many of those
endowments are well known uh on kind of
a similar way of they had gifts but then
they also have been great stewards of
that capital um you mentioned uh having
more of an appetite for risk and one
thing that's really interesting is if
you look at a number of endowments they
basically look at diversification
they're trying to protect the capital
that they have and grow it right it's
concentration builds wealth
diversification protects it
but
risk is a very interesting way to look
at why endowments are different because
in some ways diversification should
provide that protection
but if you diversify into a bunch of
risk assets then you know how do you
kind of think about diversification but
also overlaying it with risk assets yeah
this kind of gets into i think how wash
use application the endowment model is a
little bit different than how it's been
done historically
um i would say if you look at if you
were to actually look at most endowment
institutional portfolios
and actually look through so you're
primarily investing just zoom out a
little bit real quick the way you're
really investing is
we're finding what we think are the
world's best investors that operate in
any asset class or geography
uh that we think will reliably produce
good returns we're trying to find those
that are well aligned with us where
there's reasons that they should
continue to be able to outperform and
try and concentrate into those
uh you know is it as as much as possible
um
sorry i forgot where i was going with
that um in terms of uh we can edit it
yeah um
picking like risk versus diversification
so actually if you look at most of these
portfolios they're way over diversified
so if you were to actually look through
all these funds across these different
asset classes in geography and look at
your dollar exposure to every company
that you're getting you're massively
over diversified and you you're
overlaying all this active uh
performance fees on top of all that so
the ones that do really well you're
paying out a big portion of the profits
to them in fees and the ones that don't
it they don't
they don't cross-collateralize one
another right what are the dangers with
too much diversification
yeah it's that you can't generate alpha
i mean we have just the math is
unforgiving you're gonna pay out five
percent you've got a four or five
percent
uh you know inflation rate and we want
to grow that in real terms like gender
in a zero interest rate environment i
mean it's not the same today but like
generally speaking
um that's a really high bar and these
markets are super competitive so yale is
the like prototypical endowment that
that pioneered this model in the 1980s
they've done an exceptional job and you
can actually look at the dollars that
they've added it's pretty amazing but
what
when they were first starting that and
every endowment and institution copied
them after that
it's not like there were 10 000 venture
managers around the world 10 000 buyout
funds um there was kind of aggregate
alpha to be had there were opportunities
that weren't getting funded in each of
those areas that more capital coming in
catalyzed
i i
you can't really quantify that but i
would argue that's not the case today
where you have too much capital in each
of these areas too much competition
there are great ideas
um but there's a lot of money chasing
each of those so i think the danger
today is over diversifying like there
are there are fewer great ideas um
relative to the amount of capital that
ratio is not in your favor anymore and
so you really have to find ways to
concentrate capital into the best ideas
the bigger you are obviously you
mentioned we're 14 15 billion um harvard
yale princeton mit they're all they're
all bigger than us like scale is already
a massive you know challenge for us and
so i think
finding idiosyncratic opportunities that
have convexity that have upside that can
scale to a portfolio of our sizes is a
challenge and so
um
but over diversification is a much
bigger risk than under diversification
like you know a lot of people we're much
more concentrated than the average
endowment i don't think we're anywhere
close in any statistical sense of being
under diversified you know not having
enough assets to kind of offset one
another when they when they do poorly
how do you think about uh concentration
right to say hey we're more concentrated
is that like they have 200 managers we
have 100 and still 100 is pretty good
diversification or like how do you think
about that yeah it's a couple of
different things so
one way that makes us different um if if
you just look at how our assets are
allocated and look at others you'd say
well it's not different at all it looks
the same you're in private equity you're
inventor you're in real estate you're in
all these types of things what's
different about our model is that our
board
doesn't give us prescriptive guidelines
at a very granular level they don't say
xanthe we think you should be seven
percent in real estate like
we all know those are kind of made up
numbers based upon backward looking data
um what they basically say is if we were
to fire you all
and replace you with a passive exposure
here's how much risk equity versus
diversifying assets we'd be comfortable
with that's roughly a 70 30 portfolio so
within our risk
allocation
the
guidance that we have is pursue value
based upon the opportunity set don't
don't pursue it based upon some sort of
category that you place on a fund or an
asset
go after value where it is and avoid
uh investing capital where it clearly
doesn't compete very well so as a result
of that we're all generalists so we each
have areas of specialization like i've
spent a lot of my time historically in
venture and things like that you don't
discard that expertise when someone has
it uh but the difference is a lot of
places will say pop your adventure guy
go out meet every venture fund and come
back and tell us what you found and we
don't have any way to calibrate what
you're saying we're just trusting you
so we have to bring each other along for
the ride and the conversation that we
tend to have
around the table is why do we need this
what what does this give us that we
don't already have we don't want to have
10 early stage enterprise sas vcs if
there's one really great one great let's
justify that and that's that's our
exposure let's find a way to scale that
uh over time but those are those are
some of the things that that make us
quite a bit different we also
you know a lot gets made i think of our
our co-investing and the the scale of
that that we've done
part of that is
it's just a way to express our
conviction in our partners and their
best ideas
to a way that kind of normalizes our
denominator for theirs so when we're
looking at an at a manager
we're generally looking for someone
whose capital base is smaller versus
larger who manages one fund versus
multiple strategies who invest cash
dollars alongside of us and who can't
get rich on management fees they have to
get rich if we do well above and beyond
you know some sort of market benchmark
so that's really what we're looking for
but a lot of times in just a made up
example say we're 150 million dollars of
a 500 million dollar public equity fund
um and they are pounding the table on
one position this is the best idea we've
ever had it's 30 percent of the fund
we'd say great put 100 of the fund in it
we don't care it's 150 it's one percent
position
on our endowment now even the most
well-lined manager is probably not going
to take 100 position
but for us we look at that we've got 45
million of exposure like we would
actually much rather if you say that's a
three to five x and we independently
underwrite that and kind of concur with
the investment thesis and that it's
differentiating relative to other assets
we have in the portfolio we want more
than 45 million bucks so can we solve
that by letting your investors opt into
a side vehicle or an spv that allows you
to choose your level of concentration in
the overall portfolio so that's that's
you know part of the answer to your
question i think
it's unique because you have 14 15
billion dollars but you're looking for
asset managers that have smaller funds
and so is the difference made up with a
lot of direct investing and a lot of
kind of spvs via these managers yeah i
mean the the way that we're
um
you can almost think of it as is kind of
a scout program um a global multi-asset
class best of breed global scout program
where but it's almost in reverse whereby
you know if you were an early stage vc
and you know a lot of firms have these
scalp programs now where they put one
percent of their capital and allow you
know these you know engineers or
executives to use their network to make
really small investments
um ours is kind of the opposite where
the bulk of our assets say two-thirds of
our assets three-quarters of our assets
are invested in these scouts um we're
investing in them because all those
characteristics i mentioned we think
they're world-class investors
operating you know fishing in ponds that
we think will produce trophy fish
and we want to scale up their best ideas
let all those best ideas across those
diverse areas compete for co-investment
dollars so that the top part of our
portfolio is really concentrated and
really idiosyncratic in call it you know
one to three to four or five percent
positions at the endowment level so size
them in a way that can really produce a
lot of tracking error
we want to deviate from our benchmark
and our peers and that's going to be
great in some years and it's going to be
super painful in other years but we
think you can't have your cake and eat
it too you can't hug your peers in your
benchmark and material outperform them
over long periods of time you can
minimize the risk of underperforming in
a given year and minimize your career
risk or you can take that and make sure
that your
governance structure buys into that
strategy and can can see it through you
know the good years and the bad
so that's kind of that's kind of where
we look to make those co-investments
have an impact
explain this more so yeah if the entire
peer group is plus or minus you know
five seven percent from each other uh
and you all are willing to deviate from
that in either direction is that because
you're willing to do things they're not
willing to do from a uh investment
opportunity standpoint is it you just
take more risk is there leverage is like
what is giving you the ability to
deviate whereas maybe they don't want to
do it yeah i think
part of it stems from because we're
generalists i i feel like
my sense is that we do less things than
we would do if we had specialists on the
team you know if if you
tell someone hey go develop expertise in
oil and gas
like they're going to do that and
they're going to come and pound the
table and tell you they've got a great
idea so i think over time
uh you end up being more diversified in
those types of portfolios where you have
specialists that go off boil an ocean by
themselves and come back and say here's
here's my best idea and no one can
really calibrate those opportunities so
i mean we're investing in early stage
venture in the us
uh
you know
in asia in latin america we're investing
in we have crypto dedicated funds we
have
hyper-concentrated public markets
investors in the u.s in frontier markets
in in sub-saharan africa so
like calibrating those things against
one another uh high-quality investment
opportunities it doesn't really work in
a spreadsheet you kind of all have to be
there
and be
sharing and part of the conversation to
understand how these things fit together
it's kind of a you know finger in the
air type of exercise but you just have
to get reps
uh doing it so
you know it can be it can be a challenge
at times uh but i think overall
we differentiate one by just not doing a
lot of things that you do in a more
specialized model like we just we can do
private credit or real estate or real
assets
but we just don't do very much because
when a team of generalists looks at them
you have a better sense of your
opportunity crop opportunity cost across
those different areas versus if you're
just a specialist looking in one
direction you're gonna have a harder
time calibrating whether what you think
is the best idea really is the best idea
let's use this as an example so real
estate or private credit right if you
were to evaluate those and let's say
that you all said hey it's interesting
but it doesn't fit what we're trying to
do yeah is it more likely to get written
off as an investment opportunity because
it doesn't provide enough upside there's
too much risk is it a combination of
both like what are some of the major
reasons why you would avoid investing in
a certain strategy yeah yeah it's a
great question i
a simple way to put it would be they
don't really have that much convexity um
[Music]
you know the return distributions tend
to be much more normal uh in real estate
and private credit in particular like
you tend to have income oriented
investors that are willing to pay a
higher price
than someone who's letting it compete
against something in venture and we're
willing to accept a lower
you know expected return you know if
there are tighter bans around it but
only to a certain degree and so you look
at some of those assets like you know jp
morgan may have they have a strategic
non-financial reason to own xyz building
in new york it's like core to their
business like we're not going to compete
with that's an extreme example
um
pension investors want to like match
assets and liabilities and are willing
to
lend to things or fund things at a lower
rate of return than we would when it's
competing against all these different
assets that have you know more upsides
so we tend to be more focused on things
that have absolute upside and they may
have higher levels of risk higher
uh probability of permanent loss of
capital uh but they're uncorrelated with
other assets in the portfolio so and
when i mean uncorrelated i don't mean on
a day-to-day month-to-month basis i'm
talking about over our time horizon
whether the you know uh space launch
company versus the brazilian fintech
versus the you know biotech
uh you know platform
uh the asian e-commerce business
those things
they can be affected their prices can
move in tandem with each other based
upon gdp prints and inflation and you
know macro shocks and russia invading
ukraine and all this type of stuff but
over a five three five 10 20 year time
horizon that stuff kind of washes away
for the most part um
so i i would say
that's
um that's kind of a key aspect that goes
into those decisions for us
given that the team is all generous
which is rare um when you see a new
market or you see a new uh potential
strategy what's the process to actually
underwrite it right it's not like you're
saying hey we have uh oil and gas
opportunity in new mexico let's go get
our uh mexico oil and gas experts
right right so
given some of it will be simple hey it's
venture capital and we've underwritten
100 different funds and you know we
understand how to do that but when you
see something new what is the process
that you all try to pursue to get your
heads around it yeah i think ultimately
um
we're trying to get at the underlying
assets we're almost trying to abstract
away
uh certain aspects of of the investment
thesis at the at the manager level and
get to
uh what are the underlying assets this
is going to give us exposure to if we're
going to be able to directly invest in
something what are those opportunities
going to look like does that
uh does that fit our needs for our
absolute you know return goals is it
different than something that we already
have is it better
um i would say a couple things
especially in venture and
in crypto and things like that the
world's best founders uh the world's
best executives owners managers always
have a choice of who to partner with
right if you're pre like
you you go to market and you you
effectively choose your cap table so we
always have to answer the question in
those situations well why would a
critical mass of founders that kind of
fit these characteristics choose their
capital over 10 000 other uh people that
would choose to give it to them can be a
harder question to answer but we do
spend a lot of time talking to founders
we really plumb the washu alumni network
as much as we can there's tons of great
alums at venture capital firms that are
software developers we spoke with one
yesterday that works for a company in
town here
you just get really high fidelity
uh information i'm like who did you
raise from what was that like who did
you talk to who did you not talk to what
partner did you know that that can be
really valuable and insightful
um
so i would say generally speaking the
underwriting process is case study
driven like we just want to understand
soup to nuts uh how did you find this
company what was interesting about it
what did the negotiation process look
like do you understand the business what
does it do what what is your expectation
for what the company how the company's
going to perform what metrics are you
watching
um
and and how it's going you know thus far
so it can be a little bit different in
say early stage venture versus public
markets versus you know real estate
where there's maybe a redevelopment
opportunity or something like that but
for the most part our entire
underwriting process is case study
driven
and that continues after we invest with
a manager as well like we actually don't
spend
much of our time looking at new
potential partners we have a pretty
small number
we think we're better off
getting to know
a smaller number of partners best ideas
really well and creating a prepared mind
for there's a washout in the market
there's a co-investment opportunity and
we've already done some work to know
whether we think this is interesting
we're a 15 billion pool of capital but
we only have a small amount of
incremental dollars available at any
point in time to invest so we kind of
have to have a good sense of what in our
portfolio is interesting because i'd
much rather be able to deploy 50 million
dollars in a single asset that we know
alongside a partner that we already have
trust
then spend my time boiling the ocean for
you know an incremental partner who's
probably just gonna you know add
diversification you know to the
portfolio so we tend to spend time with
our partners and their companies we were
in boston last week spent two days with
a company that we're heavily co-invested
in early stage venture firm um you know
we own almost 20 of the company
uh directly and indirectly and we're
effectively treated like like a board
member so we just think that's a much
better use of our time than continuing
to ocean boil how did decisions get made
right there's some venture capital funds
that say uh actually we don't want
consensus we want any one individual
partner to be able to make a certain
decision up to a certain amount yeah
maybe if there's a bigger decision you
need some but not all other venture
capital funds are hell-bent on we need
consensus in order to do it
how do you all make decisions yeah
uh i would say the generalist model has
actually been really helpful for that so
anything that
the way it kind of works is we all go
out and it's undefined
hunt for things that you think might be
interesting so
find where the venn diagram between
portfolio need and absolute you know
interesting uh overlaps
and go spend time there so the way i
typically approach it is i will do a lot
of
intro calls meetings by myself or if i'm
traveling with one colleague this week
you know we'll meet a few a few groups
and then you slowly kind of say that was
interesting
let's do another call and walk through
one or two case studies you know in
greater uh detail
um and then you just kind of essentially
repeat that with a broader cross-section
of the team so everyone just hears
directly right and then we were
constantly traveling together or meeting
together in kind of a team format and
the conversation just unfolds over
whatever the underwriting period is
whether it's a couple weeks or six
months or whatever the case may be a lot
of times the gating factor is more like
this is actually really interesting we
just we don't have capacity to do this
like or we we just don't need another
uh venture firm in the portfolio today
is the default no you have to be
convinced for sure absolutely yeah yeah
i mean
um you know we really have the way i
counted is we have roughly 30 partners
across early stage venture late stage
venture public markets in every
geography around the world
um you know crypto real estate real
assets everything buyout that we can
invest in it's a pretty small number
so
yes the default position is no
and we when we do look at new
opportunities like we could all sit back
and never leave st louis
and spend all day meeting with partners
who are asking us for money and we just
think it's a much better use of time you
get higher failure information to just
go out and hunt and travel especially in
emerging and frontier markets you spend
a ton of time on the ground in those
places
you just meet more interesting people
you develop better trust with people you
meet people that you otherwise wouldn't
um
the the conversations are
richer in person than they are on zoom
or something like that breaking bread
all that all that type of stuff
and really honestly the alumni network
has been has been a really interesting
thing as well and that's just it's just
better in person so
i would say the
the direct answer your question is it
just evolves from a conversation of
everyone being involved in the
underwriting process
um we're trying to be better about you
know killing things early you know
we want to have a really good
anti-portfolio it's okay
to say no to good things
um and you just have to be comfortable
with that there's way more interesting
people and strategies out there than
than we want to have positions in the
portfolio because
again we we want to have enough partners
that are world-class investors in every
area but not so many that we can't pay
attention to what they're doing
walk me through like an emerging market
right so do you
send part of the team there to travel
you just walk around do you try the
introductions to people like how does it
work in terms of uh you're literally
going geographically somewhere different
but there also may be a difference in
types of investment opportunities
capital structure i always tell the
story that uh i traveled to india a
couple years ago and every founder i met
was like i have a hundred thousand users
and i was like oh my god that's like
incredible right and then they were like
no that's like equivalent of like a
thousand in america so you know there's
some uh uh kind of uh society and
cultural things that may just be
different like how do you break that
down yeah typically again we're leaning
on our partners so we had i wasn't on
this trip but we've done this before
we had a team go to brazil this spring
you know markets are melting down brazil
in particular is getting absolutely
hammered so we have multiple partners
that are they're active investors across
both public and early stage venture in
in brazil um in latin america generally
and
so we'll reach out and say hey we're
looking to go if if you all are planning
to be there we'd love to travel with you
and do some meetings with you so
oftentimes we'll try and center it with
a partner travel hand in hand go to
meetings with management teams with them
uh and then add in other meanings so we
may we i think in that particular case
we traveled with one of our kind of
public crossover partners that's done a
lot in brazil met kind of re-underwrote
every single publicly traded beaten up
you know fintech uh name out there
uh and then leaned on some of our early
stage venture partners that have assets
in the region and met with a bunch of
those companies as well like hey if
we're if we had slots for three meetings
who are three management teams that
you'd be comfortable introducing us to
that you think are are really high
conviction bets for you so that's that's
kind of the way that we do it and then
you just network grows you know we know
some family office lp's down there so
you get some market color and things
like that there are other venture firms
we haven't invested in that you know um
are always happy to take take meetings
and just get market colors so that's
kind of the
the framework i would say an anchor it
tends to be an existing portfolio
company or partner and increasing
especially in markets like this it's
really helpful to travel with them and
it increases our
well hopefully it increases our
conviction in what they're doing and
their relationships with management
teams and ability to assess the business
things like that in some ways it's no
different than if a journalist wants to
write a story they kind of go and they
start to network if you're
an individual who's trying to sell into
a corporation hey who do i know who can
introduce me to somebody to somebody uh
and so in some ways you're just
investigating yeah right the market and
trying to understand it is that fair
it's it's a very good analogy i hadn't
really thought about it that way yeah
that makes it it's uh it's fascinating
to think about that yeah i guess maybe
even like the police trying to do an
investigation or something it would kind
of be similar yeah uh i i don't know
it's uh it's like you're on this journey
and you almost don't even know what the
answer that you're looking for is yet
but but and still learn that's exactly
right and it's like that with sourcing
it's like that with trying to spend our
time on you know the existing portfolio
versus the prospective portfolio uh fund
managers versus companies
all of it is unknown there is no
playbook the markets are constantly
changing you know the interesting thing
about our portfolio too is there's
there's always a cycle somewhere
um so a lot of our
you know
partners when might show us a
co-investment opportunity or something
like that
and it's it's the best idea that they
have and they're really pounding the
table but we have this interesting perch
where
um if we're doing our jobs well
we have a really good sense of how that
best idea and that opportunity set
competes with what's going on in brazil
or just you know china something like
that
uh so our our actual opportunity cost is
from a different opportunity set you
know than most of our partners and so
it's an interesting place to be it's
hard to stay you know on top of all of
it but we really have to lean
on our partners and just be quick and
reflexive and again prepared mind is a
word that you hear a lot a phrase you
hear a lot in our office like how are we
preparing for what could come explain
prepared mine yeah uh
i would say proactively investigating
uh things in our portfolio that um like
the prototypical example would be
uh
it could be private or public but a
business that we've gotten to know over
a period of time that is organic in our
portfolio through one of our partners
where we have some reason to believe
that
and it could be a bunch of different
situations that this could be a really
big position for us if we position
ourselves correctly to participate in
future financing
um you know there could be tender offers
and and things like that there could be
uh secondaries um or it could just be
the stock is getting decimated in the
public markets right
and so we're always
trying to
have a i don't want to say a shopping
list but have a good sense of where the
most interesting opportunities are we
don't want to wait
for
you know
a global pandemic to hit and everything
to wash down and then be starting from
square one in terms of well we have
capital to rebalance like we could just
buy equities but we could also like load
up on individual assets that really have
convexity or misunderstood by the
markets so the initial covet drawdown
was a pretty good example of that we
actually
were fortunate to go into that with
significant both cash and fixing fixed
income but also you know in a perfect
world we'll always have some passive
equities as well
just a few points that can always
uh you know
serve as a source of funds for
idiosyncratic opportunities you're happy
to trade passive for active exposure if
you find the right active names we went
into that drawdown
uh with a lot of firepower and
in hindsight you wish you would have
used more of it but i think we did a
pretty good job of using a lot of it
um but that was and we're all
transitioning to work from home right
and uh basically on zoom 24 7 can't
travel stuck in your homes but
re-underwriting the entire
uh portfolio and you know there were
some cases where so this market is just
really beating up let's just add to this
fund or this name in particular is
totally misunderstood as to how this is
going to affect it let's put some
capital into this individual name
alongside one of our partners
um so that's the kind of
environment that you want to be prepared
for so explain this more so coveted is
probably a great example you guys have
some dry powder right that's sitting
there and you don't expect covet to
happen but you're just kind of hey if
something happens we've got some money
uh as that unfolds you've already done
some work or maybe even a lot of work
how do you decide what is the best
opportunity because that was a unique
situation where the macro environment
was uncertain there was also uncertainty
around how certain assets would respond
was the fed going to step in were they
not public health how would be affected
you're not allowed to go to the office
right there's a lot of moving parts but
uh
it's the quintessential like when
there's blood in the streets yeah
lean in and get greedy uh how did you
guys kind of think through what actually
to do there yeah uh yeah it's a good
question i mean i think especially in
that environment it's almost hard to put
yourself back in those shoes even we
lived it in in it was easy right right
yeah yeah exactly but at the time i mean
we had one of our
bio partners who buys really small like
local services businesses calling us and
saying i mean kind of in panic mode like
i might have to mothball these
businesses and how do we come out on the
other side and what how do we pay people
and keep the business intact because all
of our weak competitors are going to go
away if we really shut down for 18
months or two years
and that didn't really didn't really
happen um
but you just didn't know and so i think
in that environment
whatever decision you make
you have to not necessarily be as
aggressive as you you might want to be
you have to you have to hold you have to
have some humility about the whole thing
and what you can know and what's
knowable and all those types of things i
i think i know who that partner is i
think i've heard him publicly talk about
that exact conversation right be sure
yeah yeah right
and so maybe like brent's actually
probably a pretty good uh example where
uh i had heard that story from his
perspective which was hey he's been
public about it so it's not there was
uncertainty
i called you know somebody who i thought
was a trusted partner and it was like
essentially just like what do you guys
think
help what do you you know how should i
think about this or whatever
and from his side it was like they were
really great partners right i think was
like take away from the way he told the
story and you've used that word partner
a number of different times how
important is that partnership and how do
you think about um
when you first enter it and then also
almost like deepening the partnership
and trust over time
yeah i mean i think people
respect people that do the work and we
try and do the work and we try to not
you know i think lps can have a
reputation of you come in you know you
invested with someone say what's the
update you know you haven't done any
work you're just in consumption mode
you're not really invested in the
portfolio
um one
there's a lot of disadvantages that come
with our size one of the advantages is
that you tend to be one of the bigger
partners and you tend to be a higher
profile partner and people
you know want to do well it's
reputationally bad if you
sour on them or redeem from you know
those types of things
so it's extremely important to us i mean
everything's a relationship business
right and it's amazing how small these
worlds are you just have to treat people
uh you know really well and it comes
back to you and direct and in very
indirect ways
so
partnership is very important to us
we're only as good as our partners i
mean we're generalists in every sense of
the word like we're fluent in business
models and how to underwrite a business
but we're generally
uh starting with a stacked deck when we
do that in terms of we already have what
we think are the world's best investors
curating an idea for us and and we're
more validating that and seeing how it
fits with our overall portfolio
so the way that we
um
you know the way that we build is we try
and be there early you know we're not
investing in the mega global cap uh you
know global you know uh private equity
or public equity firms we're generally
trying to find people that are young
people that are hungry one of our
partners uses this in reference to
management teams looking to back but
record and runway we want people who
have long runways but also have you know
a track record or credibility or some
sort of reason but they also have a chip
on their shoulder so you know we've done
a few first-time funds this year
in both cases it was people that
had been investing at other firms and
decided to go out on their own
and do something a little more
specialized absolutely love that because
you know they always get the
the problem of like
uh well are you actually good or is it
just that you worked for that firm and
and that's it and you know so they're
even though they have a track record
they're i wouldn't want to say insecure
but they're eager to prove themselves
right
um so absolutely love that uh and
they're all young they're in 30s you
know things like that so if it works we
can be there for a long time but we want
to be there early we want to be there
first we want to develop that trust and
just support them along the way like
if you've ever met scott's god it
doesn't get rolled over on terms doesn't
doesn't lay down um is an extremely hard
negotiator and gives very blunt feedback
we all do but that's our mo like hey
we're gonna tell you if what you we
think you're doing is a bad idea whether
it's a company that you're investing in
or something you're doing with
fundraising or fee structure or
something like that
um but we're all that's your decision to
make and you know we're here we're here
to support you so i think we
differentiate ourselves just by doing
the work by coming into a meeting and
skipping over
right to the things that really matter
um and getting into actual we want to
underwrite these businesses alongside
them because that's what we're signing
up that's what we're getting uh is
exposure to the companies that they
invest in
and that that's what they're going to
show us in return is an opportunity to
size up in one of those things on
occasion yeah one of the things that's
fascinating to me is uh warren buffett
obviously gets a lot of credit uh for
being one of the best investors in the
world uh and people think that living in
omaha is like this great advantage you
guys uh being in st louis yeah uh how
important is that to having such a great
track record or is that just kind of
not maybe not as much causation as
people want to it's interesting
on the investment team any anyway we
don't have anyone native to st louis but
most of us are midwest i'm from
wisconsin
uh mike's from chicago andrew is from
you know iowa scots from alaska uh so
it's a very kind of like
midwesterny you know kind of um
kind of interface i think where it helps
is that
and i'm not i'm not
i haven't lived in an office and worked
in an office in midtown manhattan but
there's a high volume of things you can
look at that just come through your door
and people come through st louis it's a
big enough town there's enough
institutional capital where companies
and managers come through st louis but
for the most part it does create an
extra incentive to go out and hunt
and so
we can't just sit back
and
if if we do it's just adverse selection
all day long right and so we have to get
out of st louis it's a pain in the butt
to travel from st louis you can't travel
direct anywhere you know you can't even
travel to san francisco direct anymore
um
so i think it just creates
you know more of a you know front foot
forward you got to be an athletic stance
you've got to be you know going after
things so that is definitely a cultural
element to us and i i just don't know
whether that exists or how
differentiated that is versus versus
other peers but we definitely don't get
a ton of noise in st louis so there is a
little bit of you know aspect of of why
warren thought being in omaha was was an
advantage as generalists what kind of
background do folks have when they join
the team is it i'm a generalist that was
just that another endowment no i'm
coming over or do you go find people who
you know are working some random job and
say hey do you ever thought about being
an investor hey yeah um
we have done some of that but
it's it's different i probably myself
and mike dora on the team probably have
the more traditional backgrounds um
out of you know school finance economics
uh worked in asset management or
institutional investment consulting
something like that and found endowment
management as a more interesting place
to allocate capital within that broader
ecosystem no sales no marketing you're
just going to work for one institution
where you know the fruits of whatever
you bring you know what it's going for
like that's a pretty you could make more
money probably a goldman or something
like that but who cares like that that
sucks
um
but
other than that scott
is really interested you heard some of
his background if you've heard him on
other podcasts but he's from alaska went
to school in iowa played basketball
incredibly smart uh very
um
very sharp intellect very good with
numbers but went off and ran uh
derivatives trading deaths in san
francisco chicago london and tokyo like
lived in tokyo speaks fluent japanese he
would say it's not fluent but it's
pretty good as kids were all born in
tokyo and then moved back to iowa to
take
a senior investment person job and
endowment had never worked in a downward
never thought about it got the call
didn't really know but that was his alma
mater
so he's interesting because grinnell was
much smaller in terms of assets small
team so you had to be generalist there
were no choice but to be a generalist
but because he wasn't kind of bogged
down with the way we've always done
things you know mindset
uh he would have done it that way
regardless and so he's he's really kind
of discarded a lot of these
you know institutional norms and more is
that that that you're supposed to do in
this environment and just said well that
doesn't really make any sense why would
we
invest in this even though it's a bad
idea because it fits in this bucket and
we need to fill this bucket like let's
not do that
so there's a whole bunch of of stuff
like that
that i think
you know to whatever extent washi's
model is is interesting or different
that's what a lot of it is driven by by
having someone who's really sharp
um
very talented investment mindset that
didn't kind of grow up in in that
environment yeah talk to me about
bitcoin and cryptocurrencies you guys
have obviously done some stuff there uh
there's some endowments or other types
of institutional asset managers who
think grace thinks in sliced bread let's
go put a bunch of money and yeah there's
a lot of convexity and like we're all
gonna get uh you know uh great uh kind
of uh pats on the back because we're so
smart we invested in crypto yeah others
have a 180 degree different mindset and
like we're gonna lose all our money
let's say as far away from this as
possible and like this is going to end
in disaster
what was the process like in terms of
you all just evaluating the market and
what have you chosen to do there so far
yeah
i mean one thing that is very fortunate
about our model in in allocating through
what we think are the world's best
investors
is they can educate us they can be the
first line of
education for us on our behalf so
going back to
2014
2015 we had one kind of generalist let's
say mid-stage global vc partner really
concentrated very different not not
not um very high profile on purpose
uh that kind of got the bitcoin maxi bug
very early on participated in the us
marshals auction
bought a
boatload at whatever that was 700 a coin
or something like that that was kind of
our start of like okay
i don't know it sounds stupid sounds
interesting we maybe we should learn a
bit about a bit more about it so they
were very invested in that ecosystem
and i'd say
my sense is similar to you although i
don't know quite as well like very
bullish on kind of just the store value
digital gold you know type of long-term
thesis for for something like bitcoin
and open to you know ethereum solana and
you know things like that and use cases
but maybe
that that's not the majority of it right
so that's the use case to have high
conviction in going to hold it never
going to sell a coin
uh that investment was actually made
not out of a traditional fund but like a
permanent capital
vehicle where we were shareholders who
weren't limited partners and the design
the goal was it was supposed to be
around forever small number of investors
are on the table you could imagine and
this is a bitcoin 5 000 or something
grew to be like a very significant
percentage of the fund
um
and not everyone liked it equal hand so
there was some conflict in terms of uh
you know
what do we have should you sell it like
this is you know bullcrap um they were
having trouble getting an au this is
before the auditors figured everything
out and how to do this like i remember
hearing the story like and they have a
very sophisticated this is before
institutional custodians really before
nighting and things like that existed
um or were super prominent anyway um
you know doing this private key ceremony
for these kpmg or whoever it was one of
the big four auditors something just
like blank stares like i i don't get it
like we can't do it
um a lot's changed uh since then but
that was kind of the start of our
educational journey eventually that
particular conflict
became big enough where they said fine
like we don't want to manage this for
you if you if you're so intent on hating
it so
you have a choice you can we can either
liquidate it for you and send it to you
in cash
um give us your wallet and we'll send it
to you and you custody it yourself
or you can opt into our
private uh custodial solution that we've
set up and we can walk you through all
that and all that stuff so we said well
what are you gonna do they said same
thing we're always gonna do we're never
gonna sell any of it we said great just
hold it for us we've since diversified
custody but
that i mean it's obviously come down
quite a bit but like
not a material part of our portfolio you
know at bitcoin yeah epic was bitcoin um
it's still a very material position
haven't sold any of it i i really highly
doubt we will and we've had other
partners that have organically had
material positions in it some of them
have traded a little bit more and and
liquidated and distributed it
um so that was kind of the start i would
say also was it like 2017 the ico boom
it was actually helpful timing for that
to happen because our prior cio left at
the end of 2016 that was the year
they hired scott and scott was getting
on board
and so there's all this stuff going on
you're really not going to invest in it
when you've got an especially something
like that you have a new cio coming in
who may love crypto or may hate it you
just don't know so that stuff wasn't
going to happen but it was a great time
to just investigate so met every single
manager that was out there spent a bunch
of time diving into the ecosystem
really under i think started to
understand the potential here
wasn't obvious what the real world use
cases were what was actually working and
being used in solving a real problem but
you started to build it um
some of those relationships that we met
uh then have converted into you know
actual uh relationships today where over
time we've just gotten gotten there
so we've had a couple other generalist
firms that
have gone down various rabbit holes and
we've done some directs it's typically
been infrastructure picks and shovels
types of things maybe an exchange
outside the u.s something in kind of
gaming you know vertical uh applications
things like that
um so i would say
i didn't i haven't run the numbers
recently but including those types of
things custodians exchanges the the
gaming infrastructure picture shovel
stuff it's
uh multiple multiple points of the
endowments
that's pretty aggressive right in the
sense of again going back to kind of the
start of our conversation where it's a
new area uh there's convexity to it to
some degree um
and
it's either going to end up going really
well and you're geniuses or you end up
losing a lot of money yeah and uh that
helps pull you away from kind of the
peer group right in either direction
it's it's very clear though a lot of
like i said earlier a lot of the
conversation around our table is like
why is this interesting in an absolute
sense like how could this go really well
and provide material alpha at the
endowment level
and how is it different from other
things in the portfolio and it's
actually pretty clear you know in in
this case that that this is different
this is diversifying over a long term
time horizon i think where we struggle
with a lot of this stuff is
um even if you believe and there are a
whole host of different personal
opinions on our team even if you believe
yep blockchain crypto is going to eat
the world
jp morgan's gone you know all the
exchange like it's just going to take
over everything
i think where we want to be compensate
or want to be thoughtful about it is
what's going to when is that going to
happen
and what do you have to believe the
adoption curve is in these different
verticals
yeah you know fun size matters a lot i
would say correct you know and and and
the stage at which you're investing so
you have to believe to invest in
um
you know billion plus dollar fund that's
going to deploy in 18 months
and they own five to ten percent of 50
like
the math is pretty unforgiving in terms
of what you need to believe in terms of
market cap creation to generate a 5x or
whatever the number is on that fund
um so we have done some dedicated crypto
funds they've tended to be smaller tend
to be earlier stage
um
how do you because we don't want to have
to believe that to be true for that to
be a great return yeah how do you
balance um you meet somebody that has a
small fund today yeah 10 20 maybe 30
million dollars uh they find success so
kind of it validates hey we made a good
decision here um and it looks like we're
gonna drive some returns they then go
out and they raise the 50 to 100 million
dollar fund and fund three is you know
100 to 250.
and then next you know they're on their
fund for and you're oriented in a way
where you want to build long-term
relationships with partners
but to your point the financial
kind of
potential return on a 500 million dollar
fund is a lot different than on a 20
million dollar fund totally and so how
do you kind of think through
maybe continuing to invest with great
partners where you've got a lot of
conviction and you've built a great
relationship versus are there times
where you say hey we love you yeah 500
million or a billion or five billion or
you know even 100 billion dollars
whatever one side like at some point do
you tap out and say look we just can't
get there in terms of how the math gives
us a great return yeah absolutely and it
happens it happens a lot and we have to
balance
you know there can be the the anchoring
you know well
60 million is three times 20 million so
you know
is that is that material so you kind of
have to look
it looks it looks like a lot in terms of
percentage increase but
you have to understand like
what are they investing in what could
they have invested with the same um
you know value proposition to founders
in the case of crypto or venture or
whatever
uh you know
being kind of a
uh
you know fill out around
check in a seed or series a
is is a lot different than leading a
series a is a lot different than leading
a series c and the kind of analytical
frameworks versus you know backing a
founder and some qualitative you know
you know market-oriented things that at
that stage
so you really we really have to step
back and do the bottom-up what do we
think they're good at um
what does that imply about the number of
investments the size investments they
can make
and
you may be able there are many cases
where you're investing in something
early and you're saying hey we actually
think if they do the same thing they
can't they can raise a 500 million fund
and still do a great job and this is
more of a proof of concept you can think
about the first couple funds as maybe
one you know kind of bigger fund to
prove the thesis
you know in in a staged uh manner but a
lot of times it just becomes an asset
gathering exercise and you can just look
at the management fee dollars based upon
the
the the the legal documents of these
funds and say like okay this is a profit
center now and it changes that it can
change the dynamic right um
so you want to have those people that
are
that are super hungry
that uh that are
not
taking whatever management fee dollars
they get and you know buying vacation
homes and things like that but are
investing in the team do you ever ask
oh like did you guys ever like as part
of the diligence are you ever
uh trying to get at like we see you
raised a five hundred million dollar
fund there's two percent fee
we're not mathematicians but like we had
to do that math absolutely uh
where's that money going and how much of
it is like being reinvested into the
firm versus going into people's pockets
like how does that conversation happen
yeah i mean you can just ask it right um
and just have a conversation about it
it's the craziest thing someone's ever
said back um
yeah that's uh
i don't know i don't i don't want to
reveal too much
are there like crazy things people have
responded with
like almost like extreme honesty or is
it usually just like
and that's not exactly what we wanted to
hear and so yeah
it sounds like there's a really
ridiculous story that you're thinking so
don't say lunch i guess but
um all right yeah uh but my last
question for you is just
long-term orientation of endowments in
general
what is long-term for the endowment
itself right like the endowment
technically is forever right how are you
uh but you have a team and uh it's
amazing to think that everyone's gonna
be there forever and let's say okay
everyone's gonna be there forever uh but
that's 30-year maybe 40. if you're
really lucky you all are working
together for 50 years right uh which
would be incredible right
but even 50 years versus forever is
still somewhat short-term and so how do
you think about
what is the timeline that when you think
of long-term orientation is that a
five-year 10-year 20 30 50 like what how
do you think
yeah i mean i i think it's you know
three plus years i guess would be the
i think you have to be honest about
what you can know and how far into the
future you can know it and so you know
where this kind of comes into play in in
our conversations a lot is
predict if you have like a direct or
say a size up in a publicly traded
company and it rips and runs
you know it's very easy to say hey we're
a permanent capital investors just let
let your winners ride you know all that
type of thing all those types of things
and that's true
but i think we try our best
to balance like okay
yes great business but let's be honest
what we underwrote initially what our
partner underworld initially like let's
take some money off the table because we
always have we have this great
opportunity set and very high
opportunity cost where
um if you can redeploy you know three
acts your basis and something that
that's up you know 5x or 10x and keep
your your cost in the business and fund
another investment that's earlier in its
investment thesis playing out we have to
be be honest about those things i mean
there's
um
you know there's only so many
incremental dollars we have to deploy uh
every year um
so
i think we're always this has been an
interesting environment as well just
simply because so much has been pulled
forward
and so it's it's very tempting to think
yeah everything's going to be up into
the right forever and it's like well i
don't know this is like 2026 types of
stuff that already happened and so i
think
i think we did a good job probably not
we'd probably again in hindsight you can
always look back everyone wish they sold
more exactly
but
we have this kind of infinite buffet
line problem
where
um
you have a limited amount of plate space
and you have this but you don't want to
fill up on on salad um
you know because there's prime rib at
the end but you don't really know uh
when it's coming so we always have to be
uh
taking chips off the table where we can
and reserving room for something that we
haven't seen yet that comes down the
table the worst thing that we can
possibly do maybe not the worst thing
but
a bad scenario for us is having an
exceptional 5 10x opportunity with a
high conviction partner and not have the
capital to be able to invest in it so we
want to always make sure that that we
have that while also maintaining that
long-term orientation so i think it
comes down to just being reasonable
and conservative
uh about what uh and you just have to
recognize too that like market cycles
are super violent and so take some take
some chips off the table and that's
where the big debate tends to come in
yeah i mean which is a rational view of
the world right where can we send people
to find you on the internet or if they
want to get in touch with uh with you or
your colleagues where could they go yeah
i mean all of our emails are on
endowment.
i'm on twitter as well um aj kirk ajku
rki so always reach out there that's
been a great place for us to find out
what was the url
uh the url will send folks uh
endowment.endowment.edu wsdl
awesome well i appreciate it very much
thank you i'm incredibly impressed by uh
what you guys have done and uh
unpacking the thought process behind it
uh usually is a good way to prove uh
although some people may not agree it's
not luck
right that there is some intentionality
yeah and so excited to see what you guys
do next appreciate it thanks man hey you
did you like this video great we make
five of them a day and post them here on
this channel make sure you subscribe
like the video and see you next time